être à l'écouté des plaisirs wa faire
participer les citoyens aux décisions de
la municipalité le pilier du programme
de patrick jane eyre et de sa liste
plaisir notre ville notre avenir
plusieurs propositions comme la création
d'un conseil municipal des jeunes ou la
mise en place de conseils de quartier
entre les habitants et les élus
municipaux des conseils de quartier
seront agrégés sur ce que nous allons
appeler un conseil de développement
participatif plaisir aux avec lino
réfléchiront sur des sujets stratégiques
à très long terme la ville de demain
le pmu lan local d'urbanisme pour 2022
le plan local de déplacement le plan
d'alimentation territoriales dans cette
liste des personnes d'expérience ex
membre de la majorité actuelle puis des
citoyens souhaitant s'engager pour la
commune ce qui m'a vraiment séduit
c'est ce projet d'avoir une équipe
plurielle qui à la fois à semblent
différentes sensibilités différentes
compétences et qui puisse servir un
projet qui ressemble un peu à l'image de
plaisir avec ce tout se mélange
d'énergie positive en rencontrant les
habitants patrick l'inter et son équipe
ont identifié cette thématique
environnement santé sécurité entre
autres des priorités avec déjà des
mesures concrètes et des objectifs de
manière à mieux gérer notre d'émissions
carbone pour l'amener à zéro d'ici 2050
pour la baisser de 20% sur le mandat
pour investir 20 km de pistes cyclables
avant la fin du mandat
ça c'est entre autres quelques exemples
sur les axes sur lesquels nous allons
travailler d'autres propositions comme
la mise en place de navettes
interquartiers la volonté d'attirer au
moins dix médecins sur la commune avant
2026 la possibilité de recourir au
référendum pour décider de certains
projets